okay I am NOT saying that Donald Trump
will win re-election in 2020
but I am saying that the left and
Democrats can almost guarantee it if
they keep up some of the antics that
we're seeing right now today I will
present to you an anti playbook for
Democrats for 2020 which I will be
talking about this is stuff that
Democrats shouldn't do okay let's take a
look at the list first of all let Trump
set the narrative and this includes our
recent discussions about Twitter yes
Donald Trump often makes racist comments
there is not a election to be won by
having endless debates about how racist
were Trump's comments Trump using
Twitter and using the media to set the
narrative is a way that Democrats will
lose control of the 20/20 campaign and
it will help Donald Trump get reelected
every day that Donald Trump's racist
tweets create yet another 24-hour news
cycle of debate over how racist it was
and I'm not defending any of what Donald
Trump has said or done is a day that we
are not focused on issues and why people
should be voting for a Democrat for the
White House in 2020 instead of Donald
Trump
number two continuing to argue publicly
about impeachment I've said it before
and I will say it again since I'm
summing all of these points up today
Democrats need to decide are we doing an
impeachment inquiry now and if so do it
are we waiting and are we going to do an
impeachment inquiry at some point in the
future maybe six months from now that
we've determined will be more damaging
to Donald Trump's re-election campaign
or if that's the case shut up for now
and do it in six months or number three
are we going to move on and we're not
doing an impeachment inquiry and we're
gonna forget about it and we're just
gonna try to win the 20/20 election on
the issues no matter what public debate
amongst Democrats and infighting about
if when how or whether to start an
impeachment inquiry is not going to help
remove Donald Trump from the White House
in 2020 number three debating issues of
minor concern to voters I don't want to
spend a ton of time on this one because
it really probably deserves its own
segment but this also relates to the
idea of spending too much time on losing
issues the entire part of the last
debate about raise your hands if you
will give free healthcare to
undocumented immigrants there is a very
important philosophical debate to be had
around that and it is a debate that is
basically happening within the left
because the right
for the most part says no we're not
giving free health care to undocumented
immigrants in the general election
that's a losing issue and what I hope we
see in the subsequent debates the two
night second democratic debate that's
going on this week the September debate
when it comes to questions about health
care or whatever else Democrats need to
take back the narrative from these
poorly framed questions by the debate
moderators it's partially the fault of
the debate moderators I will admit and
we need to stop sort of rallying around
what in the general election are going
to be losing issues and free health care
for undocumented immigrants in the
general election will be a losing issue
and I understand the merits of it but
this is again a playbook for winning not
a playbook for being right
philosophically okay um there's advice
floating floating around about Democrats
should focus on just one issue Democrats
should say there's so much noise out
there and Trump's tweets and the border
and taxes and all this stuff Democrats
should focus on only one issue I think
that is a losing strategy very often you
hear that that one issue should be
healthcare Democrats can walk and chew
gum at the same time or at least they
should be able to at least the person we
want to put in the White House should be
able to focusing only on one issue even
if it is as important an issue as health
care is not a winning strategy and
Democrats should not take this one issue
approach another thing that Democrats
really need to not do is allow Donald
Trump to divide the left the Pelosi
versus the squad stuff that we talked
about last week there is a really
healthy and important debate to be had
within the Democratic Party about is
this going to be the party of the
center-left
like Hillary Clinton and Jobe
Nancy Pelosi or is this going to be the
party of people like Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren when it comes to
presidential candidates and what is the
role of the squad versus Nancy Pelosi
and sort of figuring that out
allowing Donald Trump to take advantage
of that to insert himself in it to take
sides to drive a further wedge between
sides of the Democratic Party this is a
way to lose the 2020 election and
Democrats need to be aware of how so
many of Donald Trump's actions and the
people around him are designed to divide
the left in that way not understanding
how to spend money is going to be a
downfall of the Democrats in 2020 if we
don't figure it out Donald Trump is
going to pour money into advertising in
the Midwest the Midwest was the
difference-maker forum in 2016 it was
really close we need to understand how
to spend money I would love to get money
out of politics in 2020 there will still
be money in politics well Democrats need
to figure out how to spend it uh and
then also we should not try to win the
election trying to change the minds of
Trumpets you know my thoughts on this
already this is about turnout this is
about getting our base out and by our
base I don't mean 60 plus year old
Democratic voters who have voted for 40
years that's a different type of base I
mean people who are clearly against
Donald Trump but who may not vote okay
you can get 10 of them to vote probably
with less effort than you can change the
mind of one trumpet so we are not going
to win this election by changing the
minds of Trumpets and then the other
thing Democrats should not do is ignore
voter suppression until November of 2020
every election cycle I do this and I
tell you we need to continue talking
about all of the voter suppression
tactics throughout the periods between
elections and I've been doing it to the
extent that I have things to talk about
and there are things to talk about if we
wait until you know October November of
2020 to try to sort that out they will
cheat okay we have to turn out new
voters in a large enough way to
overwhelm the Wrights efforts to cheat
while simultaneously fighting the
reductions in voting hours fighting all
sorts of voter
urges that are going on and everything
else that we've been talking about
relating to voting machines and voting
machine lobbyists and foreign
interference in elections and Mitch
McConnell's complete lack of interest or
willingness to participate in stopping
that foreign interference we've got to
deal with that and we also need to make
sure that we get the vote out to such a
degree that we can overwhelm the efforts
to cheat that the right will employ if
something is missing from this anti
playbook for twenty twenty Democrats let
me know I guess I should add don't run
to the middle right and I may be that
that's sort of it's so obvious that it
didn't even occur to me to put it on the
list but we've talked about this before
Democrats right now should not be
running a centrist platform we need to
actually run a platform that represents
the progressive values that matter and
that are important let me know if
something's missing from the list